Also hier ein oder drei Fragen mit „Hallo“,
okay, das hört sich ziemlich beängstigend an, aber ich
schätze, ich wähle eine Farbe richtig aus, ja, du kannst
wählen. Die roten Fragen sind wirklich unangenehme
Fragen für dich und die grünen sind
harmlos, hmm, aber sie passen zu deiner Farbe
bzw. zu dir  Weißt du, was ich
langsam anfangen und mit Komfort vorgehen werde und mit
Grün weitermachen werde, okay, okay, ich würde ein grünes
Spiel für dich schreiben, interessant, okay, ja, ich bin
nervös, du bist nervös, nervös, ein bisschen
nervös, warum tut das Grün so viel?  Es ist
ja okay, okay, sicher, was hier kannst du
lesen, was das Geheimnis deines Erfolgs ist. Na
ja, ich kann dir sagen, ich bin der einzige
singende, tanzende und sprechende Frosch im
Showbusiness. Okay, wie könnte ich
erfolgreich sein? Ich habe keine Konkurrenz, also
ist das ein nachgebildeter Vater  Wie Sie wissen,
war das so einfach, ich denke,
ich würde gerne ein rotes nehmen, ok, ich denke,
ich sollte ein rotes nehmen, gut, ja, ja,
es gab also ein rotes, ja, also
bin ich nicht ganz Offizier  Rotes, böses, oh ja,
siehst du, ja, ja, ja, ja, wann wirst du
Fräulein Pig heiraten?
Eigentlich habe ich nicht vor, Miss Piggy zu heiraten, weil
wir seit ungefähr 35 Jahren zusammen sind,
aber ähm, ich weiß nicht, ob ein Frosch und ein
Bild tatsächlich heiraten können oder nicht. Ich bin mir
nicht sicher, ob das legal ist, okay, du weißt, dass es
richtig ist, ja, du  Ich habe recht, also bleibe ich
dabei. Okay, ja, okay, also letzte
Frage: Rot oder Grün. Ah oh, lass uns einfach
Rot nehmen. Okay, ja, das Letzte, Rot, Rot,
Rot, wird schon aufregender. Ja,
ich bin einfach total zappelig, also
Hier, okay, das ist wirklich schlimm. Oh, deine
Stimme kreischt so. Ja, warum
singst du mit dieser Stimme, oh, weil es die
einzige ist, die ich habe, okay, also können wir es jetzt schaffen,
kreischende Konkurrenz, okay, ja, warum
machen wir das nicht, okay, was läuft
ja?  Rainbow Connection Ich würde
das gerne mit dir machen